and anyway so tim hydeker
yeah so we brought it up last time on
the bonus episode because we watched the
trailer right yeah
so he did an hour-long stand-up special
of purposely bad comedy yeah
intentionally awful comedy yeah an
hour long and i'm pretty sure he toured
it too
because there's a lot of people in the
comments that were like oh my god i saw
this act in so and so city
and it was so funny and so there i mean
i was that's the one thing i was
thinking the whole time when
he was saying stuff i said i know this
dude is crazy enough to
commit to this so that there's truth to
some of this
what do you mean when he's like when he
said oh i've toured this all over the
globe and
or all the country and it's tried and
proven material and i know it works
and i thought i bet he's done this
before
i mean you think about because i told
him to matt last time he was like man i
was like no way and i was like but you
think about
an it's a it's essentially an hour-long
sketch it is
you don't just memorize that over the
course of a weekend you
have to do it over and over and over and
over and over again to do anything for
an hour long and have it
be bang on exactly how you want it to be
yeah yeah
and what like what other what other way
would be better than actually touring it
he can make some money and
i mean he must have i mean i've heard
all kinds of stories of tim
just doing live comedy and committing
you know i
i remember reading i'm not exaggerating
five six years ago about him
doing singing open mic [ __ ] like with a
guitar
and people going yeah he was like not
nice he was really rude and
got mad at people for not taking his
[ __ ] seriously and talking during his
set
and it just makes me all think like oh
was that
that's for this yeah probably you know
what i mean yeah he's just
testing it out okay i'm gonna do this
character yeah well there's there's
youtube sketches there's videos of him
it's called tim heidecker goes to lunch
with and i forget the other guy's name
but he's a comedian
what the [ __ ] was he in he's famous but
he's wearing that same
scumbag comedy guy outfit the leather
jacket over like the shirt with the
jeans yeah tim and gelson gelman have
lunch but this is from seven years ago
he's been doing this character for so
long and like the thing is none of these
videos have that many likes because
people don't really get it
because it's like super real it's just
like them both being shitty comedians
oh okay views from people that have seen
it are just
nuts for it you've been doing flying
stuff how long
uh well when's february that's like
three months ago yeah
so i've been doing it for like a year i
set it up like this i say
um listen i don't want to get bombed i
get it
i don't understand why there's so much
security but between the shoes
and the taking your computer and the
liquids
it's like i want to go on vacation but
i don't want to rip up my constitution
at the same time
interesting interesting it's funny it's
funny
it's just this and there's like six of
them okay
all right yeah so this is he's had this
yeah
for a really long time yeah oh here i
think he finally just said okay i'm
gonna do this i'm gonna really commit
and do it
12 years ago this is oh seven isn't that
same
fit he's been really so we maybe we're
just not in the know like we
yeah i'm not i love tim and eric
but i'm not like a super fan like when i
you know kelsey and i's first date was
at a tim and eric
yeah show yeah and we walked in and did
people were wearing you know the most
niche uh jokes on their t-shirt
okay that did not make sense to us at
all you know some deep cut from like
some early tim and eric sketches and
everyone there you could tell i've been
to like every single show
hell yeah and we were just kind of lost
but i [ __ ] love these guys
anyways definitely watch this special
yeah yeah
the yeah it's like an hour what is it
let's get the title right man an evening
with tim hi decker yeah
that one part where it just goes into
the benefits of e-trade
dude and he goes and the best part is
there's still people on ameritrade
you don't get any of those features and
then he just moves on to the next
looking thing
and you know it's like there's people
that still use ameritrade
even though they don't get those
features
anyway yeah it goes on to the dog yeah
bro
dude i love like it's like what i was
saying last time you know like a
i think i said it last time because a
super literal stand-up special
ah [ __ ] what is it that damages last
time like
when me and cash did that hike i was
saying it'd be funny if someone did a
super literal stand-up special
let's say i went to the gym the other
day
that's it just went to the gym yeah
then went home it's just like you just
like just drag it out for way too long
like there's no punchline
oh this guy's just talking about his day
he did that yeah yeah yeah
like i made a smoothie and here's the
thing the protein that i use
it's chocolate flavor it doesn't really
taste like chocolate
it tastes like fake chocolate you know
it doesn't doesn't taste real it tastes
more like chemicals than anything else
and so i drink this thing and i'm full
for like the whole day
because the protein is just like i have
to get enough pro like i'm tracking my
macros and so
it says i have to get 100 grams of
protein premise
building up to something the whole time
that's kind of what happens in a lot of
that final joke oh my god
oh my goodness bro oh my goodness man i
was hysterical
yeah i couldn't we won't ruin it but
we'll say he like [ __ ] up the joke like
multiple times
and since he's filming a special he just
he goes we good
you guys are like shut up and he tells
the audience to shut up so he can
re-film that
you can read like take the joke and then
the audience laughs again he gets all
mad at him cause he's like how's that
gonna cut
it's not gonna cut okay nothing's funny
about what i'm saying right now
it's really good just watch it he he
just does that
he does that character so good like
everything down to the facial
expressions and the way he like
it's so good meta bro yeah you know
so yeah tim heidecker
uh what the hell is i gonna say put
put on my little music thing this week
see if everybody hates it oh are you
putting it out this week
when friday nice i mean it's all like
centered around this [ __ ]
insane visual that i'd [ __ ]
i don't know that thing is i'll be
paying for that one
for a minute did troy cut it yeah yeah
troy cut it nice
detroit well so what a new video will
have come out by now
yeah is that coming out today by this
comes by the time this comes out
it may have been out already okay so
maybe tomorrow
yeah okay okay yeah so that was a
[ __ ] experience as well yeah
yeah so we can talk about it yeah i
think so
sorry excuse me just the the call was a
lot longer than what
went on you know uh
yeah it made me feel like
if we did another one in person we could
just [ __ ] around because
she wouldn't uh she wouldn't be offended
yeah i think that was something i think
we were both like a little bit like oh
we don't want to be rude to her
yeah because we are like for the first
like 20 minutes yeah but then we kind of
got into it
and then and she i mean she broke the
ice yeah
she did by the way we did a tarot card
reading for anyone who hasn't seen it
yet yeah we did terracotta but it was
like over the phone with this woman
yeah that that does it and she was
hilarious
yeah dude and we kind of [ __ ] with her
at the beginning and then she was like
really serious about the tarot card
stuff so then we were like okay let's
not [ __ ] with her but then she started
[ __ ] with us a little bit and then it
got loose and it got super funny
yeah i mean dude like she uh
uh i what i loved about her was
when we hit her up like when i hit her
over to do the first video she goes
you know elena says oh we're gonna put
you on video is that okay she said
yeah i'm confident in my skills i love
that line from her i'm confident in my
skills
yeah she didn't ask where it's going she
didn't ask for a link
didn't care this [ __ ] could have been
for hbo
she didn't care she said and it's good
for my business
yeah i show she said and then
originally originally i i wanted to do
it in person and she said ah
covet i'm not comfortable she said but
that's a cute idea
like just filming a tarot card video i
was i was a little bit offended i was
like
it's a little bit condescending it's
cute cute little yeah it's a little bit
nice little white a little video
yeah for your little channel yeah so i
said oh okay we'll put you in the hot
seat yeah
huh yeah and then she said i don't care
i'm confident in my skills
and then yeah just the whole the
the one thing that i feel we missed out
of the experience was seeing the cards
i think that's a big one yeah having
because
yeah in front of you yes so you can see
because they're visually they're like
scary scary i was gonna say crazy or
stunning or they're scary they're just
straight up someone makes me scared some
of them are horny as [ __ ] though
really that two of cups card with the
girl crying i was like that's like
that's a little
yeah it's a little horny yeah yeah the
two cups of wine behind her she's in the
lingerie she's like two cups one two
cups one girl
yeah two cups one girl yeah she's she's
like running her hands through her hair
yeah it's like it's like it's like just
under cheek yeah
yeah like well that it's the horny card
that's that's a horny ass card right
yeah you've wait a minute you've been
horny online yeah
are you commenting on mister no no no
no
and then the sun card that dude was
ripped yeah
and oh you haven't seen the next edit oh
wait did you guys edit the cards over
the
yeah so yeah the next round came out
yeah oh i i started it i saw like the
first it had titles and stuff like that
yeah yeah yeah
yeah so i headed i didn't watch far
enough the sun card is
ripped hers is ripped okay that's the
other thing with tarot cards you can get
all different kinds of cards
the ones that uh we had
you know they looked like an optical
illusion book or something you know
everyone was like 2d and they look like
they're drawn by like a three-year-old
the ones that oh yeah
the ones that she was sending us those
were hard as hell yeah yeah
all t-shirts all could have been merged
oh 100
we should do that just rip tarot cards
for merch every time we do a video like
this we should drop merch
specific [ __ ] video and be like yo
new tarot card merch for all the people
that are [ __ ] with the video like
it's like
you know major [ __ ]
some rooster teeth [ __ ] yeah oh man
uh um yeah but okay so when we were
doing it
i was really scared right yeah really
scared because
like for example we were walking down
the boardwalk with
with our friends like two years ago yeah
and we're walking in front of those
apartments that are in front of the
paddle bar
paddle ball courts sort of and or no
they're right by like that
that new sneaker store where like the
freak museum used to be
on on the venice boardwalk anyways
there's some apartments right there and
there's a palm reader
that lives in there and she like does
her business like right on the balcony
because it
goes straight to the boardwalk so we all
went up and all the people in the group
got it done except for me i
would i just refuse because i'm like if
in this small
chance that this is real i don't want to
[ __ ] know if i'm gonna die or if i'm
going to not get married or get married
or i don't want to know
i just want to play this out how it's
meant to happen you know
and so this scared the [ __ ] out of me
and then when we're doing it
she's asking you know she you can you
can she's really good at what she does
but you can
tell like you can tell what she's doing
yeah the way she talks and everything
it's like a david blaine type thing
it's just like you know a lot of it is
when something's not working that she's
saying we go
no she just all of a sudden jumps to
something else yeah and they were like
yeah and she's like
doubles down on that yeah and then so
we're only thinking about the things
that are
making sense that and we can relate to
and then the whole experience feels like
she really spoke to you because there
was a couple moments in the video where
she's like
are you guys uh dating or or
do you she said like she was basically
trying to guess
yeah things in our life yeah yeah but
the way tarot cards lay out is that they
can have multiple meanings
yes it gives you a yeah you know a
little tree yeah
a little it gives you room to work but
who knows because mercury is in
retrograde right now and so she said the
whole thing would be kind of
unstable yeah the whole session would be
unstable misunderstood misunderstood so
maybe i misunderstood the whole thing
maybe it is real yeah and you just
you just weren't vibing properly as long
as i don't ask cancer
i'm fine you know that will never not be
funny i know
tarot card readers saying you got ass
cancer
never not be funny
you